let's get to our five headlines
[Music]
all right let's get to our uh five
headlines and i don't have this
actually written down as a headline but
i saw it right before
we started here that cardi b is getting
divorced so very sad development i feel
like that should be the number one
cardi b was married to a gentleman named
offset i don't know if that was his
christian name
greatest romance of our time cardi b an
offset and they are
getting divorced you know who would have
ever thought that rolling around on the
floor naked
and singing about your [ __ ] may not be
the healthiest thing for your marriage
i i didn't see i could i couldn't i
never could have seen that coming
but all of our hearts are breaking today
um all right anyway let's get to the
real headlines
reading from fox news says on tuesday
president trump was joined by israeli
president
uh benjamin netanyahu uae foreign
minister abdullah
bin zayed al-nayhan and bahrain foreign
minister
khalid bin ahmed al-khalif there we go
to sign the abraham accords something
the president hailed as the dawn of a
new
middle east however says fox cnn's
coverage of the event
was less focused on the groundbreaking
peace agreement and instead shamed the
white house
for holding such an event amid a
pandemic during the network's 3pm
program cnn anchor brook baldwin accused
the president of denying the science
there we go
of coronavirus citing the over 195
thousand deaths
um she later negatively emphasized the
hundreds of people that attended the
outdoor
white house event and knocked the
president for holding a packed indoor
event
in arizona okay so there you go of
course cnn has to you know find
something else to focus on
you've got a historic peace deal this is
what they're this is what they've got
they're going with because they're
pathetic
frauds but i will say
put putting cnn to the side on this
peace agreement i've criticized trump
plenty uh and with no aggress no regrets
about that
but the man has been i think pretty
easily
uh the best foreign policy president
in decades at least and i'd give him
that title just simply based on the fact
that he hasn't started any new wars
and it's sort of sad that that's where
the bar is right now don't start a new
war and you're the best
foreign policy president in a generation
but but uh that's that is where it is
and now you add this on top of it and i
think easily
he wins as best foreign policy president
uh in in decades
in my lifetime really number two on the
uh one of the sheriff's deputies who was
shot in that assassination attempt
in los angeles over the weekend has been
identified her name is claudia
appalinar 31 years old mother
was a librarian before becoming a cop
and she's currently still in the
hospital under guard for her own safety
of course
expected to recover thankfully now this
is a pretty remarkable story
you got a young woman young mother
decides to leave her job as a librarian
gets into law enforcement not but a year
maybe a little bit over a year into
becoming a deputy she's
shot in the face and the torso multiple
times and what does she do
you know there's the video of this with
a with a bullet wound in her
face bleeding profusely hardly able to
speak
presumably in intense unimaginable pain
she helps her partner apply a tourniquet
you know for all she knows she's moments
away from death and what is she doing
she's
she's caring for her partner this is
real heroism i mean this is a badass
woman right here this is what that is
so why isn't the left champion
championing her why aren't they blaring
the trumpets
about this story why aren't they telling
her story at all this is a hero woman
uh it's it seems like also a hispanic
woman
taking care of her male partner after
sustaining a gunshot wound to the face
you think this would be the kind of
story that our liberal friends would eat
up
i mean they're constantly coming out
with movies um with with
fake versions of kick-ass females who do
this kind of thing
here's the real thing the real item in
the flesh
and they don't seem very excited about
it we all know why because the left has
devolved to the point where they aren't
allowed to celebrate
or honor anyone who is not a violent
criminal
all of their heroes recently are violent
criminals they have no
heroic heroes all of their heroes are
scumbags who happen to get shot by the
cop
cops that's that's the requirement for
being a hero on the left today
being a real hero disqualifies you um
that's the left but the rest of us the
rest of us can honor and celebrate this
woman
incredible story there uh number three
you may have noticed
that those riots in lancaster that we
talked about
to start the week seem to dissipate
pretty quickly
um one night of rioting and then it's
it's done
that we haven't heard anything else
about lancaster now this is in contrast
to portland seattle
where it went on for months on end
kenosha it went on for weeks
in lancaster one night and it's done
why is that well i think this might help
solve the puzzle
according to the new york post several
of the rioters arrested are now facing
one million dollars bail now you can see
right here
uh this is the their mugshots one of
them is a
the the blonde chick there one of them
she's a sorority girl apparently
and now she's in jail and she can't get
out she's got a million dollars bill
um they're all learning you know this is
what happens when you pull this crap out
in the country
and it's not just bail police in
lancaster they came down
hard on the rioters they were using tear
gas the very first
night they didn't they didn't they
didn't spot the rioters
two weeks to riot before they even tried
to enforce the law no
immediately they were out there with
with uh in full force
tear gas and um and there are videos of
them
you know rolling up in vans not unmarked
vans
liberals who don't need to freak out
about that they are they are marked vans
but they came
they identified the ring leaders of the
rioting
and they singled them out and they they
rolled up in the police fans
and they took them and arrested them and
now they're facing a million dollars
bail
so what do we learn when you give these
punks consequences real consequences the
problem goes away
lancaster came down hard arrested people
harsh penalties what do you know
rioting stops and that's why we don't
need to hear anything about
resources that's one of the excuses
we've heard
in places like portland and seattle we
don't have the resources to
what resources do you think lancaster
has
this is amish country
how often do you think the police
officers in in amish country are dealing
with rioting
it's probably the first time ever and
yet they were able to put it down that
quickly
simply through enforcing the law and
having real consequences because most of
these people that are out riding
they don't want any part of that they're
doing it for fun they're doing it
because they're nihilus they're doing it
because
they've got misdirected rage and they're
just in there and they're they're just
spraying it in every direction
you start you start making it real for
them and it goes away
all right where are we number four this
is fascinating from the daily wire again
a group of astrophysicists say they've
accidentally stumbled upon
a possible hint of life on venus
an unexplained chemical that could
indicate the presence of bacteria or
even ongoing activity associated with
specific chemical processes
uh live science reports that the team
was trying to get a baseline read for
phosphine from a planet uh venus not
thought to have
phosphite in the in the atmosphere and
then it turns out that it does
and there's a lot of scientific-y stuff
here that i'm not gonna read but
basically
phosphine is a sign of life uh because
the thing with phosphine
is that it's um it uh it uh it's it
phosphonates
and it creates a uh i have no idea
actually i have no no clue whatsoever
but the point is apparently there might
be some kind of life now i'm assuming
that any life
on an 800 degree planet with a toxic
atmosphere probably is not intelligent
we're not looking at an intelligent
civilization uh probably something more
like portland
but either way i you know i've always
considered it plausible that there could
be intelligent life
in our solar system on other planets if
not venus then maybe mars
and it seems plausible to me that they
could have intelligent civilizations
the reason we don't see them with the
satellites and and the rovers and
everything is that they're hiding
underground
because they don't want us to know about
them they were checking us out and
seeing how things are developing on
earth and they said oh crap
this isn't looking good and so they're
just they're hiding out and waiting for
us to inevitably destroy ourselves and
then they can come back out and uh
live out in the open again the way i
look at it i think earthlings are a
little bit like
you know like the kind of person you
know maybe an acquaintance
who you know and but if you see them at
the grocery store you're gonna hide in
the pasta sauce aisle until they leave
because just because if they're
obnoxious and if you see them they're
going to start talking to you and
they're not going to go away
i think on a galactic scale earth is
probably
a lot like that number five a man in
oregon was arrested for starting a brush
fire
then then released so we just talked
about how to do this the right way
you know you arrest people and you keep
them this is the wrong way again because
we're back in oregon
so he was arrested for starting a brush
right he was released
then he started six more and was
arrested again
now between this and the gender reveal
party that's that we know also
caused some of these fires the link to
climate change seems to be
um becoming a little bit less clear
shall we say maybe climate change has
driven people mad
and and caused them to start fires and
do gender reveal parties i don't know
i think there was an m night shyamalan
movie that was sort of about that with
mark wahlberg if i'm remembering
correctly what was that movie called
where the the the trees were like
causing people to kill themselves
because
as revenge for deforestation am i making
this up oh it was called the happening
i think that was a movie which by the
way could you think of a lazier name for
a movie than the happening
what should we call the movie i don't
know things are happening in the movie
maybe
the happening um finally we just did
number five here's a bonus i
i i can't i can't not play this i really
enjoyed this clip this is nancy pelosi
on cnbc uh yesterday
with jim cramer and here's what happened
what deal can we have a crazy nancy i'm
sorry
that was the president i i have such
reverence for the office
i would never use that term but it is
but you just didn't
but you just did you know what i mean
you know
the reference i have for the office is
so great
no he was he was right the first time uh
crazy nancy
that's her name i like how at the end he
goes oh come on you know what i meant
and she says yeah yeah i know what you
meant
well what what what did you mean if not
that she's crazy isn't that what you
meant
um i i and then and then
my next favorite thing is how kramer
emphasizes the respect he has for the
office
not for her but for the office that's a
backhanded compliment which is you know
i would never i have so much respect and
love for
your office your office is what i like
not so much you but your office
anyway nancy pelosi not having a great
week first someone poops on her driveway
then she's called crazy on national
television
tough week for her pretty enjoyable for
the rest of us but
kind of tough for her well i hope you
enjoyed that clip from the matt wall
show if you did go ahead and hit that
subscribe button right down there so you
can stay up to date on all of our future
content